.
In this presentation we will solve a set of examples that
It deals with parallel and perpendicular lines
If we have parallel lines, orthogonal lines, and of course
There are lines that are not parallel or
Orthogonal
And with a little review, if you've seen
By, parallel lines, where it does not intersect
Let me draw some axes
If these axes are Cartesian, this is
X axis, and this y axis
If this line I draw in purple, a parallel line
It seems so
It's not the same line, but they do
The same inclination
If this moves by a certain amount, if the change in y
/ Change in x is a certain amount, this change in y /
The change in x is the same amount
That is why they do not intersect
If they have the same tendency
They have the same inclination
Parallel lines have the same inclination
Orthogonal lines, depending on how you see them
It's kind of the opposite
Let's assume that this is a line
The orthogonal line will not
Just cut the line, but cut it at an angle
Ie at an angle of 90 degrees
I will not prove this to you here
Because I actually proved it in linear algebra display, however
Oblique orthogonal line - Let us assume that this is one
Here, let's assume that the yellow line has the inclination m
Then this orange line, vertical on the yellow line
It has a tendency of -1 / m
Their miles will be
The negative inverse of each other
Now, using this information, let's look at a set of fonts
We find if they are parallel, or if they are
Orthogonal, or none of the above
To do so, we have to keep looking at the tendencies
To see, we were told that a line is going through
Points 4, -3 and 8.0-
And the other passes points, -1
-1 and 2.6-
Let's find the inclination of each of these lines
I will find the first line of the line
Tilt here, line 1
I will call it Mile 1
Tilt 1 is, let's assume it - well, I'll take this on
End point
If -3 - 0 - remember the change in y--
-3-0 / 4-8
= -3 / - This is equivalent
4 + 8-- -3 / 12
= 1/4
We divide the rugs and set up on 3
This is the line
This first line
Now, what about the second line?
The second line inclination is, well, let's take
1 - 6 / -1 - -2
= --- 1 - 6 = -7, / -1
- 2
This is equivalent to -1 + 2
Which equals 1
If the tendency here is 7
So here, their miles are not equal - if they are not
Parallel - and not both
The negative inverse of each other
If neither
Ie they are not parallel or perpendicular
They are not parallel or perpendicular
If these two lines intersect, they will not
Intersect at an angle of 90 degrees
Let's solve these more questions
I have here, again, a line going by
Points, then the other line passes through these points
Let's look at their miles
This Green Line, what is its tendency?
The tendency of the Green Line, I will call the first line
We will say, let me see, the change in y
I have done so
2. First, so I will first 1 - / 1
- 3
If -2 - 14 = -16
1-3. Equivalent 1 + 3
This is divided by 4
This is -4
Now, what is the second line inclination?
If we have this second line inclination
Let me say 5 -3, this is the change in y /
2 - 0
= 5 - -3
This is equivalent to 5 + 3
= 8
Then -2 - 0 = -2
This also equals -4
If these two steps are parallel
These two lines are parallel
They have the same inclination
I urge you to find equations for each of these
Lines and you represent each, and prove to yourselves
They are parallel
Let's do this
Again, this exercise is about finding the inclination
This first line has these points
Let's find his inclination
First line inclination, line passes
With these points
Let's see, 3 -3, this change in y
/ 3-6
This is equivalent to 3 + 3, ie 6, / 3
+ 6, IE9
If the first line inclination is 2/3
What is the tendency of the second line?
This is the second line, which is the other line
Pass through these points
If the second line inclination, let's see, can say
8 - 4 - 2 - 6
how much?
-8 - 4 = -12
2 - 6 equals 2 + 6
Where the negative signal is eliminated
Equals -12 / 8, ie equivalent if
We divided the rugs and established on 4
3 / 2-
They slapped
Note, these are negative
The opposite of each other
If you take 1 / 2/3, it equals -1
X 3/2, equivalent to 3 / 2-
Each one is the negative inverse of the other
We turn the rugs and the place, and make them
And thus equal to each other
If these lines are perpendicular
And motivate you to find equations - you've already got
Your tendencies - but they created the equations of each of these
The lines, and put them down, and prove to yourselves that they are
Orthogonal
Let's solve one another
Find the equation of the vertical line on this line
Which passes through point 2.8
The first part of the information, he
Vertical on that line there, what
Explains to us?
Well, if he's vertically on this line, his cam should be
Negative reversal of 2/5
His inclination, the negative inverse of 2/5, is reversed
2/5 is - let me write it in a better color, a beautiful green color
If the slope of this line is 2/5, equation
The line we have to find is vertical
His inclination would be inverse
If instead of 2/5, it will be 5/2
Instead of being negative, it would be positive
If this is a negative inverse of 2 / 5-
Right?
We take the negative signal and become positive
And turn the 5 and 2, we get 5/2
If this must be the inclination
We can use the tilt point model here
He goes through this point
Let's use the tilt point model
y - value of these y, and must be on line
= Inclination, 5/2 x x - this x value
X value when y = 8
This is the line equation in the tilt point model
If you want to put it in a model point of inclination, you can
The use of little reparation, or forced manipulation
y - 8 = - Let us distribute
5/2 - If 5 / 2x - - 5/2 × 2 = - 5
Then we add 8 for both parties
We get y = 5 / 2x
Add 8 to 5, and get positive 3
We're done